and uh yeah i think we'll see a result
any moment just uh we'll explain it
maybe in more detail a bit later but the
black king is going to have to give way
no matter which way the black king goes
the white king will go the opposite way
and traitor pawns will not help black
here we go the white king is coming in
now
and yeah max king
unable to help
it's getting close then i guess a win
for magnus carlsen striking back after
losing to prague in
round five
mishra giving it a good go but of course
facing the world champion
it will be hard for a 13 year old
and we saw a quick flurry of moves there
white king did grab the remaining black
pawn
and it's not only one pawn that black
has to deal with now all of those white
pawns are pushing forward
and you can tell on the body language
magnus knows it's winning and mishra
gives up
it's over a win for magnus carlsen
striking back
winning against the youngest grand
master in history it's a long and
interesting game though